can you hear us Nicole
yeah plug it in disposiba they hadn't
plugged it in whoa I think he can hear
us now he hadn't plugged it in you can
hear us now I take it yes
congratulations on the win
you seem pretty unflappable even in a
Finals game Nicola pretty unfazed by the
moment was anything different about your
day today when you got up and realized
you were going to play in this series
for the first time uh to be honest I
felt a little excitement but when the
game started it was just a normal game
and I told I told my wife not what I
don't know like I just cannot wait a
game to start just a few moment you know
you're a dominant big man how do you
decide I'm going to score or no I'm
going to get my teammates about because
this is my first time seeing you play
Live my second time meeting I Met You in
Dallas and I want to meet your big
brothers we'll talk later they're right
over there but yeah how do you decide in
the game because Charles and myself and
even Grant we were a Score first score
how do you say you know what I'm not
going to take a shot six seven minutes
in the finals game to give my guys
involved to be honest I I don't decide
it's just I just take what the game
brings me you know AJ had an amazing
first quarter he dominated the pain in
the first uh first quarter and I was
just in like that does Advantage you
know we need to give them ball and he
actually scored he was six for six in
the first quarter and I never I never
traced scoring or whatever I just I just
played the game and see what's going to
happen well I got two things first got
to give you and Coach Malone a shout out
I said before the game y'all got some
tight ass haircuts y'all got them things
y'all guys
and by the way you have hair that's
right that's right but my second
question is what the hell did you do for
nine days
I enjoyed I was finally home for nine
days there you see I have a sunburn so I
was a swimming pool I have a swimming
pool so I was in swimming pool I was
just filming with my family uh I think
we actually did a really good job like
we had a couple days off and we still
had a couple of conditioning
workouts whatever and so I think it
seems like we stay in a good shape and I
think our Felipe our strength coaches
and and coaches did a really good job of
managing uh to get arrest and still uh
still uh kind of don't get out of your
shape hey Nicole obviously you guys were
the number one seed in the Western
Conference but going into the postseason
people didn't really have you guys as
the team representing the west and just
I don't know that chip on your shoulder
is something to prove was it something
you guys just tuned out or was it you
know did you use that as locker room
motivation to take to think to be honest
we didn't even talk about it we we uh I
think we know as a team that we are
capable for doing something actually
since then is a training camp
it felt in something different in locker
room you know the guys were talking the
guys was going out to dinner hanging out
together and I think that's important
for locker room for the team chemistry
from the day one
something different happened from the
last eight years I think what makes you
very dangerous is you don't show a lot
of emotions but I know you're super
excited tell me how excited you are
first win three more wins ago you'll be
a champion how do you how do you stay
even Keel like you are now to be honest
I I'm not excited to be honest I'm I'm
really focused and for and because I
know what they're capable of I mean they
they beat some really good teams that
the teams have had better record than us
and uh we as a team we are we are not
relaxed it's it's uh it's really
important for us to especially because
they won the first game in every in
every round and we just as a team we
have a huge respect for the Miami Heat
and our our focus and our mentality is
not relaxing just to get better
you know we all Marvel at your your
talent you're playing the building what
you've done all all season the last few
seasons I'm just curious
growing up overseas like who are the
guys that you wanted to Pat in your game
after because we really haven't seen a
big in the game quite like you I think
it's Shaq
thanks a lot thank you brother now I'm
joking appreciate that to be honest I
back in back in Serbia I didn't follow
the NBA that much we know pageant and
and a lot of divots because they were
the and Russian batteries they were like
the one who first went to MBA and opened
the doors for every every other let's
say European players or players from
Mexico slavia but when I came here it
was it was Timmy Duncan it was LaMarcus
Aldridge it was borisdale
definitely you know those kind of guys
now the Serbia is not the bad players
basketball is a I see some Boris Dio in
there I see that uh basketball is
obviously a huge huge deal in Serbia
you've got a history of NBA players done
well internationally can you give our
American audience a sense of how big a
deal it is not just to have you in the
finals but you performing at this level
in the finals right now have to be
honest I don't know but I I know a lot
of I get messages and I people from back
home telling me that people getting
organized and watching watching games in
the two three in the morning right now
instead of is like four in the morning
and still they're they're watching the
game and I think that just shows that
probably they love to see someone from
their Hometown let's say playing and
performing on a high level are you
trying to tell us
just walk around Serbia like a normal
guy uh first two weeks no I'm in my
hometown in my hometown first three
first two weeks now and then I take a
day picture with everybody and then
then you've run out of people to take
pictures with but then I go around like
you got them all there is not many
people where I go so
one last thing I don't give a lot of
props to a lot of big guys but that's
true all the props in the world brother
thank you very very means a lot it
should be a lot very very very very
impressive to watch thank you very much
he's a regular old Penny white I show
around but you know what I give it up to
you big man alive right there appreciate
the time you know what you are now a
member of the big man alive
there you go there you go come test me
[Music]
a real big man right here America all
you other guys nope good game brother
congratulations
[Music]